one question is what does biden do
let's assume for a second that biden
is declared the victor and passes all of
these
lawsuits and is inaugurated how does he
lead this country
he doesn't have the senate um he has
he barely won by one of the thinnest
margins there'd been other very thin
margins obviously but
he won by a thin margin and how do you
govern how do you get a country
to come with you people talk about and
biden said it
i want to unite this country i don't
know if this country is unitable
and i'm i like to think of myself as a
an optimistic person but i think
sometimes think short of an
alien invasion where all of us have to
come together
and fight the aliens that are coming to
get us from
uh you know planet z-bar um
we i don't know what's gonna bring us
together well look i would argue that
that half 40 percent of the country
wouldn't believe they were aliens they
would think they were you know
nancy pelosi's pet dragons i mean i
don't even
think i mean look i i thought about this
this i think about this all the time
because as you know i worked for a
president 209
11 um had the privilege of having a very
united country for a while
i mean some of his decisions became
among the most polarizing
in modern presidential history but right
for a spell he had a very united country
and
american people um did more than their
part they they overcame fear they went
back on airplanes
um within weeks or months people were
flying on airplanes again
um and i think that if that happened now
i think tia you look at the resistance
toward math
can you imagine if 9 11 happened now and
the leader now had to convince people
that had to throw away their liquids
take off their shoes and be frisked
sometimes
friskily um i think half the country
would say you know screw you
yeah that's violates my that violates my
rights i have a right to get on an
airplane with a bottle of weird liquid
um and i don't want anyone touching me
yeah
so it could be ungovernable it could but
here's my thought about how binding
moves forward i mean
people just have to to put their
um their mouths and their tweets
and their behavior um you know where
their complaints have been
and for all the people that complain
mightily about what trump was and who he
was
um it would appear that the country
sided with that and they're about to get
rid of someone that was leading our
country down an autocratic
despotic path it would appear and again
it's not done
it would appear that a plurality of
people i mean
in the popular vote i think joe biden's
lead is more than four million
and and i think he'll end up with a
sizable electoral
margin that the people pick the good guy
not the autocrat
and so i i think and and this is always
easier to say from the other side of the
aisle but i think democrats will have to
resist the
temptation to go to war with themselves
is a huge deal
to win in this climate where 40 percent
of the country doesn't just disagree
with joe biden but as you said thinks
he's a
a socialist you know whatever cunan
called and pedophile
i think i think people and for all the
republicans that came out the lincoln
project
those people have to be part of his
governing coalition and if he tries to
reform the supreme court
all the people that tried to get rid of
trump have to
work for joe biden and kamala harris's
success
right